bienvenue à bord de retour le 3 octobre
sur Paris Première pour une nouvelle
saison de Zemmour et Naulleau et surtout
oublier de destin français chez Albin
Michel voudrez c'est le portrait d'une
quarantaine de figure historique ont
contribué à faire ou à défaire notre
pays ça va de Saint-Louis à Robespierre
en passant par Napoléon le général de
Gaulle et vous êtes numéro 1 des ventes
sur amazon
comment parler mais d'abord commencer
avec un petit jeu qui va nous permettre
de mieux vous connaître qui est vraiment
Éric Zemmour c'est le Dieu quizz de
lundi
[Musique]
il s'agit d'un jeu dans lequel il n'y a
que des questions sur vous vous répondez
pas mais vous confirmer des réponses des
chroniqueurs sombres voilà quel métier
exerçait le père dérèglement tailleur
ambulanciers gendarme ou éleveur de
berger allemand
[Applaudissements]
ambulancier
pour mania
pourquoi le responsable de la colonie de
vacances dans laquelle le petit Éric
Zemmour passé l'été a-t-il convoqué sa
mère parce qu'il réveiller ses camarades
en chantant la
Marseillaise.
replay
de répondre avant la fin de l'été et des
réclamations
c'était donc
voilà
alors tu es toujours dans le destin
français ma mère écouter Aznavour et
entonner à tue-tête ma vie d'Alain
Barrière
[Musique]
alors ton père lui passer ses soirées
autour du violon endiablée de Sylvain
Enrico Macias
Dylan
à Dominique Rocheteau
qui a Amanda Lear ou à personne
j'avais pas lu assez Éric Zemmour
dans Libération en avril 2006 biberonner
à la culture 68 je lisais Charlie Hebdo
écouter les rolling stones toujours les
cheveux longs et bouclés on m'appelait
Rocheteau quand on est la génération
génération
de sa vie
avec un jeune hollandais
comment humilier
c'était le bon élève qui est qui est
premier donc pour une fois j'étais pas
le premier et en plus c'était Léna le
mythe de l'État et cetera
j'ai quand même vous emmerde
qu'est-ce qui Éric Zemmour à vous
détestez par-dessus tout le féminisme
l'antiracisme
l'idéologie de gay ou les trois à la
fois
[Applaudissements]
Mounia est devant
avec qui avoue-t-il avoir correspondu
régulièrement Dieudonné Alain Soral
Jean-Marie Le Pen Carlos Dieu
le Père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à quelle époque quand j'ai écrit le
premier sexe
que j'avais
publié quelques années plus tôt
et donc un journaliste à organiser une
rencontre pour débattre et il a bien
compris que
du coup on discute
avec
tout le monde
à mon avis c'est un entretien des
intelligences avec le mot là c'est quand
même pas mal au dessus des idées tu as
été financé par les rend bien sûr et
surtout je pense que Alain Soral est
très intelligent qui a compris que il
avait un public dans les banlieues et
qui qui gagne beaucoup d'argent grâce à
ce public avec son discours je ne sais
plus aujourd'hui ce qui est de la
conviction de lui non plus je refuse
l'ostracisme en
subissant moi-même je le refuse pour le
colis avec le diable même avec une
longue cuillère
Éric Zemmour a-t-il reproché de ne pas
avoir donné un prénom français à son
enfant a Zinédine Zidane a Rachida Dati
à Barack Obama ou à sa femme
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'elle a de l'appeler sa
fille
ça me gêne
pas
et les ministres de la République
française française
et normalement chez moi
malheureusement
non
je m'appelle comment
incroyable
les gens prendre chaque jour il y a des
prénoms
Éric Zemmour Éric Zemmour à reprocher à
Nicolas Sarkozy d'avoir donné un prénom
italien sa fille Giulia ça vous embête
autant comme ça il y a
aucune leçon à recevoir de ce pauvre
type ou qu'il aille se faire soigner ou
Éric Zemmour connais pas où
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout à fait la tendance
générale c'est comme Natacha qui disais
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu que je
devais passer devant un psychanalyste
c'est la cicatrisation de l'opposition
et de la piscine c'est une vieille
méthode communiste soviétique employé
par j'adore quand on mais oui mais oui
mais oui
moi j'ai une cicatrice personne
je m'amuse
cicatrice
[Applaudissements]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu